wearing masks and social distancing
House lawmakers approve a new batch of
stimulus funds Boeing's
troubled 737 max is unlikely to win
approval to fly again until at least
late summer Ramadan in the time of
social distancing and lockdowns millions
of Muslims around the world celebrate
the start of the holy month
I'm Jason Bellini with the latest
reporting from The Wall Street Journal
on the coronavirus crisis lawmakers
donned masks and were split into small
groups in the sanitized house chamber to
vote on a nearly 500 billion dollar aid
package for small businesses and
hospitals the second infusion of funds
for small business relief will help some
of the nearly 4.4 million Americans who
filed for unemployment benefits last
week bringing total claims to a record
26 million today was an historic day for
us to once again pass our now forth
bipartisan legislation to address the
coronavirus crisis we're very pleased
with the vote 388 to 5 the president is
expected to sign the bill today
meanwhile the Treasury Department is
asking publicly traded companies to
repay loans they received from the first
stimulus package intended to help small
businesses Ruth's Chris Steakhouse and
Shake Shack said they would return funds
immediately we exclusively report that
the pandemic is expected to prolong
regulatory approvals for Boeing's 737
max until at least late summer adding to
the plane makers financial strain
Federal Aviation Administration
employees who approve passenger planes
have been hampered by state homeowners
and travel bans have hindered flight
tests for foreign pilots the trouble jet
has been grounded since March of 2019
following two deadly crashes linked to a
faulty flight control system the holy
month of Ramadan started Thursday for
millions of Muslims while many are
observing it under strict lockdown and
praying online people in some countries
gathered to celebrate the start
the 30-day period of fasting during
daylight hours in Pakistan Prime
Minister Imran Khan allowed mosques to
host prayers as long as a number of
social distancing and hygiene measures
aren't forced but questions remain over
how the measures will be implemented and
doctors have warned of the risks of
corna virus spreading with big
gatherings
[Music]